les personnages de walt disney ont bercé
leur jeunesse ils peuvent désormais
entrer dans son monde enchanté ils sont
cent soixante quatre réunionnais retenu
pour le recrutement bénin départ leclerc
mais euro disney dans notre île des
jeunes diplômés bac bac +5 pour certains
ils veulent saisir cette opportunité
pour enfin travailler et obtenir une
expérience professionnelle qui
n'arrivent pas à trouver dans notre île
qui ont décidé de postuler car j'ai vu
l'annoncé clairement sur facebook
simplement elle me suis dit que ce sera
le tremplin parce que je fais des études
de langues
ça sera un tremplin pour partir après à
l'étranger dit on va tout donner toutes
les clés pour nous rassurer
donc je pense que ça ira c'est normal
d'avoir une appréhension c'est un
changement une nouvelle aventure non
classés tout à fait normal je pense que
je suis très optimiste et je pense que
ça se passera bien putté au lycée j'ai
playback carrosserie pendant trois ans
et est maintenant je suis rien alors
quand on m'a parlé de disney c'est à
deux que frédérick laurence toute l'
aventure c'est le russe qui a postulé la
première j'ai postulé pour le poste de
vendeuse et lorsque j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient data fois susceptible
de l'intéressé
bien formés comme on voulait on avait un
projet de mobilité tous les temps tous
les deux depuis quelques mois donc on a
décidé de postuler cet été ce serait une
belle expérience pour nous donc on a
décidé de partir pour mieux revenir
s'améliorer en tous points et surtout
vivre une expérience unique à 10 l'an
passé ma prochaine avec ici c'est pas
évident de trouver du travail
j'ai moi même galéré pendant un an pour
trouver un emploi maintenant le fait que
ben je suis sélectionné quad cinéma ces
choix demain pour re disney il s'agit
d'une belle aventure et d'une vraie
rencontre avec les réunionnais ses
futurs employés représenteront la
réunion dans l'hexagone surtout d'un
ambassadeur
du rêve mais dans domaine du contact
puisque cette animation est qui
pourtant on sache on s'adresse
auchan
maputo en souriant
c'est pas sympa m c'est le critère
important des jeunes qui ont soif de
réussite à l'image de boris et
christopher ils veulent réussir pour
faire la fierté de leurs mains mais
j'avais envie de découvrir de belles
choses
riche de ravir le métier c'est de faire
rêver moi j'aime bien ce genre de métier
là avec l'animation le spectacle mon cas
là bas
je me dis que quand c'est fait pour moi
je fais site
en plus quand je rate ma mots et yann
moix c'est un peu
que plus de motivation mais qu'entend
courrier parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
s'embarquer l'année travail ça va et
puis il ya michel qui a 55 ans veut
prendre un nouveau départ malgré son
handicap il n'a pas peur de l'inconnu
j'ai créé bien des gens je suis très
motivé l'étudiant j'aime aussi la vie
parisienne
je pense entre autres à le guen arme qui
s'est entouré de tous ses partenaires
pour ce recrutement les missions locales
le rsm a le pôle emploi et personnes
retenues pour ces postes devront
patienter quelques mois les départs sont
prévus pour le début de l'année
prochaine